become so skilled so vigilant so
flat-out fantastic at what you do that
your talent cannot be dismissed so
here's my specific advice on how to
compare yourself and model success
properly they got a master what you're
going to master
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's up belief nation at seven my one
word is believed and I believe in you I
believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent adds something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference so let's start your day off
right together grab your coffee and sip
on today's message master your craft
over to you Oprah Winfrey the number one
lesson I could offer you where your work
is concerned is this becomes so skilled
so vigilant so flat-out fantastic at
what you do that your talent cannot be
dismissed stop comparing yourself to
other people
you're only on this planet to be you not
someone else's imitation of you I had to
learn that the hard way on the air live
anchoring the news one night in my 20s
when I first started broadcasting I was
19
moved to an anchor by the time I was 20
and I was just pretending to be Barbara
Walker Walters I was just trying to talk
like Barbara acting like Bravo Barbara
hold my legs like Barbara and I was on
the air and I hadn't read the copy fully
and I called Canada Canada and I did
that on the air I crack myself up
because I thought Barbara would never
call Canada Canada and that little break
through that little crack that little
moment that I stopped pretending allowed
the real me to come through your life
journey is about learning to become more
of who you are and fulfilling the
highest truest expression of yourself as
a human being so I think comparing
yourself to other people is actually an
amazing strategy can be extremely
beneficial when done properly especially
if you're trying to master your craft I
think you need to use it though as a
kick forward and not down too often
people compare themselves to other
people and say well look what they have
I can never have that I sock I'm the
worst and you just kick yourself down
about how how poor you are don't do that
use it as a push forward use it as a
tool to know what's possible out there
for you I love young Les Brown he's my
hero from a speaking perspective young
Les Brown is the man I loved watching
him speak watch him speak doesn't make
me feel inferior I look at that as
inspiration to know what's possible and
now I can't just copy young Les Brown
because I will only ever be a junior
version of him but modeling success
works if I can pull one thing from Les
Brown and one thing from Steve Jobs and
one thing from Oprah Winfrey that helps
me become the best meet Oprah when she
was getting started her career love
Barbara Walters she wanted to be the
next Barbara Walters and she studied
Barbara she want to be exactly like
Barbara and then she had to learn how to
be Oprah
like the strategy is not try to be
Barbara Walters but by comparing
yourself to Barbara you can learn from
Barbara apply what work from her to work
for you try it see it taste it see if it
feels right and then expand so I think
if you want to be a great interview host
you need to compare yourself to Oprah
you need to compare yourself to Barbara
you need to compare yourself to Larry
King and all the greats that have come
before you you can't just be a copy of
any of them because then you're just
Larry King or Oprah Winfrey jr. that's
not the path to success but you can
learn a couple things from each of these
people to help you get to where you need
to go a lot faster comparing yourself
and model and success is one of the
fastest shortcuts to get to where you
want to go as long as you're using it
the caveat as a kick forward and not
down so here's my specific advice on how
to compare yourself and model success
properly one look at the people in your
industry who have one bill Gates saved
my first company I've never met the man
but I had a software company he had the
most successful software company in the
world
I learned his strategies I applied it to
my business we started to take off look
at who has had success in your industry
and learn from their strategies apply to
your company you know that those things
work 90% of the same way at work for
them will work for you that last 10% you
need to tweak you need to just you need
to customize you can make it your own
but you do not need to come up with
every genius idea to work in your
industry success leaves Clues follow
them so that's one look at the people
already inside your industry to look at
other aspirational mentors that you look
up to take one of your heroes I've got a
bunch of people up on the wall behind me
whoever is the relevant person for you
if you love Oprah Winfrey but you're
making sneakers you can learn from Oprah
success leaves Clues not just within an
industry but across all fields so it
would take the person or the group of
people that you love that you look up to
the you respect for whatever reason and
dissect their success dissect their
mindset dissect how they look at the
world dissect how they come up with new
ideas I set the strategy that they're
using because if you can figure out how
to take what Oprah did in media and
apply it to selling shoes
you will win and so comparing yourself
to others in a positive way only as a
kick forward and not down to help you
master your craft to help you become the
best version of you I think is
ultimately how you win and how you get
there much faster now I've got a really
special bonus clip for you that I think
you're gonna enjoy but before that I
want to know how have you compared
yourself to somebody else
in a positive way that has helped you
grow learn and get somewhere else faster
how have you modeled success I would
love to hear from you leave it down in
the comments below thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso and enjoy the
bonus clip
[Music]
started starting everyone says aw you're
gonna be a gym teacher I said no I saw
my work with professional athletes I
knew what I wanted to do is I'm gonna
work with but I'm going to work with
professional athletes so that was my
that was the goal I set in my mind and I
just said hey that that's gonna take a
place in my head that's the only thing
that I want to do and I gotta figure out
a way to I got to figure out a way to
get there so I started and learned my
craft better than anybody else did I
start with the professional athletes
knowing after I graduated I went to work
in a local health club really I knew how
I knew everything from a book standpoint
but still you got to know how to apply
it okay so I you know worked with
anybody I could any these are not pro
these aren't pros I'm talking about
housewives I'm talking about individuals
that just want to get in just want to
get in shape people that have had
injuries from different sports kids
anybody just kind of developing programs
putting implementing what I've learned
and actually being able to apply it
mm-hmm and once I start to look at that
craft I said okay now I'm starting to
figure out how to how to actually apply
this stuff and how to use it and put the
formulas together and put the workouts
together and do all these different
things I mean stuff that they're doing
now from a workout standpoint I was
doing 30 years ago I knew you know I
mean some of the stuff is you are it's
different I stay on top of it right I
got to continue to learn you know
continue to be better myself so I can
better my athletes better my craft but
it's a different it's just a different
way of doing the same a different way of
doing the same thing right now there's a
lot more resources a lot more education
a lot more testing available back then
you kind of had to just figure it out a
lot of individuals now okay especially
in this generation not only from a
training standpoint but from a knowledge
standpoint they're jumping from one
thing to another you know they're using
this trainer this week they're using
another trainer next week you know
they're using this person as a mentor on
YouTube than they're using this person
over here okay and they're getting all
this conflicting information okay you
got a you got a mass
sir what you're going to master okay
you have to fit you have to figure out
too many people are jumping from place
to place the place Michael
Kobe all these individuals they mastered
one aspect of the game when they
mastered that aspect of the game then
they move to another aspect of the game
being great at your craft is a
requirement yeah yeah and I'm not I
wouldn't suggest that you stop that you
don't try and get work or hustle or do
all those other things while you're
coming up because that's a part of the
game and that's you know garyvee is a
big advocate for hustling and so you got
a hustle your whole way but being
greater your craft actually matters yeah
yeah and and having like the camera is
like an extension of my arm and you
think about it I have used the pro golf
analogy I don't know why I'd not crazy
about golf but those guys have to again
women have to stand up on the tee and
hit the ball in the middle because
that's what they're paid to do doesn't
matter if it's raining sunny windy if
there's ten people watching or ten
million they're payday at the bottom in
the middle and as an artist you're paid
to make and as an entrepreneur you're
paid to deliver the the ROI to the
shareholders and as a wrestler you're
paid to win or like whatever your thing
is you have to be great at your craft in
order to I think achieve so there's this
10,000 hours hardcore the folks that I
think are great whether they're hacking
the system and doing it in 10 hours
or 10,000 that is I think people want to
skip that step
yeah I get I get you know for every
email that I get about the craft of
writing yeah I get a thousand about how
to market books and I'm hold on the
ratio is all wrong yep that's oh no I
would agree with that and so that gets
overlooked like I just want to be this
awesome fashion photographer and hang
out with like awesome you know beautiful
people in crazy locations and it's like
dude you got a beat like actually pick
up a camera and get good that first and
then you might be able to do you know
part if you tell yourself a story long
enough you start to believe it won't you
believe it you act like I have Tulsa
what a whale out of handcuffed lightning
though thunder
now you know I'm bad all the last week I
murdered a rock into the stone
hospitalized a brick I'm so mean I make
medicine sick the fundamental key to
success is it can take between 18 and
254 days of taking action for a new
habit to stick I've created a new course
called 254 confidence or every single
day for 254 days I will be sending you a
video between 30 seconds and 5 minutes
long that you start your morning with
around making you feel confident it's
absolutely free check out the link in
the description below to get access